[Music]
josh is with us josh is in charlotte
north carolina hey josh how are you
hey dave hey john how are you guys doing
better than we deserve sir what's up
so i think i know what your answer is
going to be dave's longtime listener but
i wanted to hear it from your voice
my wife and i have talked about um i
just want i just want a verification we
have talked about what the current state
of the stock market
uh we're both investing we're debt-free
we're investing 15 plus percent in our
retirement um
we've talked about potentially
uh pausing our retirement in order to
pay off our house in about 30 years
um what's your household i wanted to see
we make about 120 okay and what's the
balance on your home
about 75
okay so i know i know dave you would say
we could pause other things
and and keep the retirement and uh and
keep it going but we have been through
the gazelle phase
we've okay you said you would pay it off
in that you said you paid off in three
years
yeah we could pay it off in about three
years three years of fifteen percent of
your income is only forty five thousand
where's the rest of it coming from
sorry i'm not sure i'm following what
you're saying okay seventeen thousand
dollars is fifteen percent of a hundred
and twenty
seventeen times three is forty five
forty six thousand dollars forty seven
thousand dollars okay
so that's not seventy five thousand
dollars so you've already are paying
extra on your mortgage
yeah we've already paid an extra on our
mortgage so you're paying about 10 000
15 000 extra on your mortgage now
yes yes okay
and you said 15 plus percent why plus
just to chunk a little bit of extra
money in there
okay so if you backed it down to
actually 15
we would increase it a little bit right
a little bit yes okay all right and so
the difference is if we do this is three
years or if we only put uh 20 000
towards it it's five years
they're they're about yes yeah so we
have a three-year or a five-year
equation
so the difference the the discussion is
two years difference
yep
the stock market's on sale right now the
last thing i'm gonna do is quit putting
money into it yeah i was going to ask
and and i'm asking uh josh i'm asking
dave this question
i'm hearing now if you've got money to
put in now's the time yeah because all
the stocks are at discounts i don't try
to time the market exactly but i i it is
always exciting to me when the market
drops right
because i'm not taking my money out i'm
only putting more in the more you put it
in a bargain that's right it's on sale
you know when we were kids the blue
light would come on at kmart and they
would have a sale blue light sale and
there's a blue light sale on the stock
market right now and so that that's uh
there's not in kmart there's nothing
blue lights anymore i know i know i know
okay don't send me more dadgum tweets
about being a boomer okay i'm with you
but the uh i get it i get it but the
point is it's on sale whatever whatever
it is you want to flash sale on amazon
whatever you want to compare it to
ramsey 10 sale i don't know whatever it
is but yeah i you're right josh you
didn't know what i was going to say
i'm not going to pause your retirement
for two years of gain
because the other thing that we haven't
used in this equation is we have not
added into this equation all the
wonderful financial things that are
going to happen to you in addition to
your 120 000 worth of income during this
five years that turn the five years into
four or three
a bonus
an unexpected small inheritance
a a windfall here or there of some kind
oh by the way your income's probably
going to go up during this five years a
side hustle and we've not we've not done
any of that yeah we've not mentioned any
of that here and all of that's going to
turn the five years into four into three
my prediction is that if you keep
putting no more than 15 percent
not plus
and you look at your budget and you
don't go gazelle intense i'm not
suggesting you cut out a bunch of other
things if you keep doing what you're
doing add a little bit here that used to
be there just take a few take a little
fluff off the sides not not any hard
cuts just tighten it up pay attention
make sure you're doing a written budget
because sometimes people get sloppy here
at four through seven they kind of relax
on the budget a little bit actually be
doing the budget every single month
and uh do be enjoying you're intentional
you're not intense
but
my prediction is still between three and
four years your house is going to be
paid for
that's what i think is going to happen
because i think there's some things
coming your way because it usually does
follow
that god blesses people who are being
trustworthy stewards
so can you give a quick primer i hear
the i hear that it's on sale
what does that actually mean
well uh okay the the market is down in
the last five years we pull up the
charts today the market's down 5.82
in 12 months okay okay so let's say it
goes down 10
uh and if you put in
100 000 and it goes back up
to where just to where it was
on its way north
um when it goes back up right just to
where it was on its way north then you
will have made an extra ten or twenty
thousand bucks so if i'm buying if i've
been i'm in this is simple for i'm
trying to smooth it out for me if i've
been buying apple stock at a dollar and
it goes down ten percent you can buy it
for 90. i'm buying it for 90 cents yeah
and then when it goes back to a dollar
or a dollar five yeah i bought the same
stock just exactly there you go okay you
would have paid the dollar for it you
got to you got on sale for 90. right and
you'd have been happy at a dollar yeah
that's right you know and that's true of
a good mutual fund you have that same
i'd have been happy at 36 000 dow
i'm happy at a 34
one thousand thirty two thousand dow to
jump in and because i'm not getting out
right i'm riding it long term but not
getting out and i'm continuing to put
monies in the slot machine not slop
that's a bad analogy i'm continuing to
put money in yeah you're chunking money
and you're dropping the quarters in yeah
so
warren buffett and a bunch of other
people had things to say when the market
dove in 2008 and it went from 13 000 and
went in half down to 6 300. 50 dropped
yeah
and they said well mr buffy you've lost
all you've lost this much money on
berkshire hathaway stock you know you've
lost a you know whatever was a half a
billion dollars and he said i haven't
lost anything
i haven't sold anything sold anything
that's right if i sell it
i've locked in the losses
but right now the value is down but i
haven't sold it
if you own a house and the house goes
down in value you don't lose money on
the house until you sell it
now if you wait on it to come back up
then you didn't lose money on the house
and and that's what's going on with the
stock market so hey that works in
reverse i've had i've got buddies you're
like man i made a million dollars on my
house and my thought is you made
anything you hadn't sold it yet that's
right you haven't you haven't made any
money so don't start spending that money
that you think you've made you haven't
made anything that's right your equity
has increased your net worth has
increased but you haven't made anything
that's right
yeah you have to turn it into real money
and then you made some money i made a
lot of money on bitcoin then i lost a
lot of money on bitcoin you can really
do either one you just watched it go up
and down that's right